This is 99% invisible. I am Roman Mars. This past summer, producer Ellie Gordon-Morshal took a trip to Reno, Nevada. While the temperature is approximately 150 degrees, maybe late July is not the best time for a pasty Canadian to visit Reno. The downtown sites are best seen after sunset anyway. All that neon, even on the cars. Where is it coming from, oh a car? That was nice. But I wasn't actually in Reno for the tricked-out cars,
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年夏天，制片人艾莉·戈登-莫沙尔去了一趟内华达州的里诺。虽然气温高达华氏150度（约65摄氏度），但七月下旬或许并不是一个怕热的加拿大人造访里诺的最佳时机。反正市中心的景点最好在日落之后观赏。到处都是霓虹灯，连车上都有。那是从哪儿来的，哦，一辆车？那真不错。但我去里诺其实不是为了看那些改装车，
or casinos, or cocktails. I was there on a run-of-the- mill 99 PI mission to find a bridge. Oh my god, now this is the bridge. I still can't get over how high pitched my voice goes there, but this was the Virginia Street bridge. A bridge I've heard many stories about. And apparently there's the long tradition of women throwing their ring in the river. This is Anne Stern. She grew up in Arlington, Virginia.
也不是为了赌场或鸡尾酒。我去那里是为了执行一个普通的《99%无形》任务，去寻找一座桥。天哪，这就是那座桥。我到现在还没法克服自己在那儿说话时声音变得那么尖，但这就是弗吉尼亚街大桥。一座我听过许多故事的桥。显然，这里有一个悠久的传统，就是女性把戒指扔进河里。这是安妮·斯特恩。她在弗吉尼亚州的阿灵顿长大。
Her mother Pat came to Reno in the 1950s to throw her own wedding ring off this very bridge. Anne's mom was in Reno to get divorced, and she was taking part in what had become a final right of passage for Reno divorcees. You'd exit the courthouse with your new divorce decree, had two blocks to the trucky river, and fling your wedding ring off the Virginia Street bridge. All to symbolize your start as a newly liberated woman. She just said the tradition was throwing the ring,
她的母亲帕特在20世纪50年代来到里诺，就是为了从这座桥上扔掉她的结婚戒指。安妮的妈妈去里诺是为了离婚，她参与了当时里诺离婚者最后的成人礼。你拿着新的离婚判决书走出法院，走两个街区来到特拉基河，然后把结婚戒指从弗吉尼亚街大桥上扔下去。这一切都象征着你作为一名新获得自由的女性的开始。她只是说这个传统就是扔戒指，
and my mother did it too. Past lawyer was there to witness the whole thing and he was appalled. He couldn't understand how she could dispose of such a valuable asset so he literally ran into the river. He was all dressed up in his suit and he rolled up his pants and maybe took off his shoes. I don't know. And he walked out into that river and he found the ring. And he came back and he said, you may need this.
我母亲也这么做了。当时的律师在场目睹了这一切，他感到震惊。他不明白她怎么能处理掉如此贵重的资产，于是他真的跑进了河里。他穿着西装，卷起裤腿，可能还脱了鞋。我不知道。他走进河里，找到了戒指。他回来后说，你可能需要这个。
Stories like these were common in Reno because back then in the mid 20th century, it was internationally known as the divorce capital of the world. Reno was the best bet for people who were searching for illegal escape from a marriage gone wrong. Reno is a fascinating place to me because I love stories about divorce. I even had a friend once tell me that I was pro break up. She didn't mean it in a negative way. It was like she was just making an observation about one of my political beliefs. Here's the thing, both of my parents were divorced when they met and they never remarried.
像这样的故事在里诺很常见，因为在20世纪中叶，里诺是国际公认的世界离婚之都。对于那些寻求从不幸婚姻中合法解脱的人来说，里诺是最好的选择。里诺对我来说是一个迷人的地方，因为我喜欢关于离婚的故事。甚至有朋友曾经说我支持分手。她并没有恶意。这就像她只是在观察我的某种政治信仰。问题是，我的父母在相遇时都离过婚，而且他们再也没有结婚。
So I didn't grow up thinking marriage was particularly important. And at the end of the day, a story about people falling in love is just not as interesting as a story about a divorce. But for much of modern history, divorce has been very hard to do. Especially when the Catholic Church ran the show. It's a sacred bond. God has blessed it, and God doesn't want you to separate. This is Rod Phillips. He teaches history at Carlton University in Ottawa and wrote a book on the history of divorce in the Western world. Divorce laws have historically been influenced by religious practice.
所以我从小就不觉得婚姻特别重要。归根结底，关于人们坠入爱河的故事，远不如关于离婚的故事有趣。但在现代历史的大部分时间里，离婚一直非常困难。尤其是当教会掌权的时候。这是一种神圣的纽带。上帝祝福了它，上帝不希望你们分开。这是罗德·菲利普斯。他在渥太华的卡尔顿大学教授历史，并写了一本关于西方世界离婚史的书。离婚法在历史上一直受到宗教习俗的影响。
And when early settlers colonized the US, they brought a range of divorce customs from Protestant Europe with them. Yeah, the early set was the Puritans were Calvinists. You know, Calvin's divorce laws were in place in the Netherlands and in Patiswitzland, like Geneva and also in Scotland. So they all allowed divorce. And when they set up their colonies and established the statutes and the laws, they allowed divorce for two grounds of adultery and desertion. But not all the settlers were Puritans, of course. There were Quakers, Lutherans, Baptists, and also Anglicans who followed the Church of England, which at that time still did not permit divorce.
当早期定居者殖民美国时，他们带来了来自新教欧洲的各种离婚习俗。是的，早期的定居者清教徒是加尔文教徒。你知道，加尔文的离婚法在荷兰和瑞士部分地区（如日内瓦）以及苏格兰都有实施。所以他们都允许离婚。当他们建立殖民地并制定法规和法律时，他们允许以通奸和遗弃为由离婚。当然，并非所有定居者都是清教徒。还有贵格会教徒、路德教徒、浸信会教徒，以及追随英国国教的圣公会教徒，而当时的英国国教仍然不允许离婚。
After American independence, matters of family law were assigned to each individual state. In other words, a state's government had the right to set the rules for how or even if you can attain a divorce. So divorce laws varied dramatically depending on what state you lived in. Some states offered several grounds for divorce while others were more conservative. And then there was New York, which only had one ground, adultery. And you had to prove it. Even if both parties in the marriage wanted out, they would need to literally stage a photo op for evidence.
美国独立后，家庭法事务被分配给各个州。换句话说，州政府有权制定关于你如何离婚，甚至是否能离婚的规则。因此，离婚法根据你居住的州的不同而有很大差异。有些州提供了多种离婚理由，而另一些州则更为保守。然后是纽约州，它只有一个理由：通奸。而且你必须证明这一点。即使婚姻双方都想结束关系，他们也必须真的策划一场“拍照秀”来作为证据。
That's where you have people getting into bed with somebody and having somebody jump in through the window with a camera and take a picture of them sitting up in bed fully closed. And everything, this is the evidence. This is the only evidence you need that the deltory had taken place. So if you lived in one of the matrimonially conservative states like New York and didn't have the resources to collude with your partner to stage an affair, you were left with one option.
这就是为什么有人会和别人上床，然后让某人带着相机从窗户跳进来，拍下他们坐在床上穿戴整齐的照片。这就是证据。这是你证明通奸发生所需的唯一证据。所以，如果你住在像纽约这样婚姻观念保守的州，又没有资源与伴侣串通策划一场外遇，你就只剩下一个选择。
Go West. The Western states tended to be more like a progressive in many respects. The Western states were newly colonized and didn't have the baggage of traditions. Just the baggage of colonization. So they looked around and came up with liberal marriage and divorce laws. They felt reflected the times. This is kind of an accepted component of our society here. And if people are going to get divorced anyway, you know,
去西部。西部各州在许多方面往往更进步。西部各州是新殖民地，没有传统的包袱。只有殖民的包袱。所以他们环顾四周，制定了自由的婚姻和离婚法。他们认为这反映了时代。这在我们这里是一种被社会接受的组成部分。如果人们无论如何都要离婚，你知道，
get divorced somewhere, then we're going to be a community that embraces that. This is Alicia Barber, author and public historian based in Reno, Nevada. She says there were a few things that drew outsiders to Reno from its very founding. Because of its proximity to gold in silver mines, Reno was selected as a stop on the Central Pacific Railroad in the mid 1800s. This made the city easy to get to for lots of different types of people. So Reno kind of became the center of the whole region
总得在某个地方离婚，那我们就要成为一个拥抱这种行为的社区。这是艾丽西亚·巴伯，里诺的作家和公共历史学家。她说，里诺自建立以来就有几件事吸引着外来者。由于靠近金银矿，里诺在19世纪中叶被选为中央太平洋铁路的一站。这使得这座城市对各种各样的人来说都很容易到达。所以里诺在某种程度上成为了整个地区的中心，
and really has been this transportation crossroads ever since and then also a crossroads of many different people coming here for a lot of different reasons. But the big thing Reno had going for it was its short residency period. Much of the population of Nevada was transient, meaning they would come for short periods of time to take advantage of the mining rush. Nevada lawmakers realized if they lowered the time it took to become a resident, they could count this transient population as permanent and use them to gain more power in Congress.
从那以后，它确实一直是交通枢纽，也是许多人因各种不同原因来到这里的十字路口。但里诺最大的优势是其短暂的居住期。内华达州的大部分人口是流动的，这意味着他们会为了利用采矿热潮而短暂停留。内华达州的立法者意识到，如果他们缩短成为居民所需的时间，他们就可以将这些流动人口算作永久居民，并利用他们来获得国会更多的权力。
So on the books, you know, by the turn of the century, you could become a state resident in six months, which was pretty quick. That meant people could become residents in a shorter period of time and in turn benefit from all the state's laws, including divorce. A shorter residency period and more liberal grounds for divorce meant that if you're wealthy enough to relocate for six months, it could technically be easier to become a temporary Nevada resident, secure a divorce, and then go home, rather than get divorced in your actual home state. Which of course made a lot of conservative politicians and social leaders in other states furious. They hated that residents could circumvent their own state laws and tried to ban this loophole. But in most cases,
所以，在世纪之交，你可以在六个月内成为州居民，这相当快。这意味着人们可以在更短的时间内成为居民，进而享受该州的所有法律，包括离婚。更短的居住期和更宽松的离婚理由意味着，如果你有足够的财力搬迁六个月，从技术上讲，成为内华达州的临时居民、获得离婚判决然后回家，比在你实际居住的州离婚更容易。这当然让其他州许多保守的政治家和社会领袖感到愤怒。他们讨厌居民可以规避自己州的法律，并试图禁止这个漏洞。但在大多数情况下，
an out-of-state divorce was protected by the Constitution. And in 1905, a famous young socialite named Laura Corey helped transform Reno from a city where you could technically get a divorce to the place to get a divorce. She was the wife of a prominent industrialist, William Cory. People didn't know why she was here, but eventually it became clear that she was here to get a divorce. The coverage of this divorce was in every major newspaper. That kind of precipitated then this awareness that Nevada and Reno in particular was a place where people could easily arrive on the railroad, establish their residency, and get over divorce and go on with their lives. So this became known as migratory divorce.
州外离婚受宪法保护。1905年，一位名叫劳拉·科里的著名年轻名媛帮助里诺从一个“技术上可以离婚的城市”变成了“离婚的首选之地”。她是著名实业家威廉·科里的妻子。人们不知道她为什么在这里，但最终很清楚她是来离婚的。关于这次离婚的报道出现在每一份主要报纸上。这促使人们意识到，内华达州，尤其是里诺，是一个人们可以通过铁路轻松抵达、建立居住权、获得离婚并继续生活的地方。这就是所谓的“迁徙式离婚”。
Luricory would just be the first in a parade of headline worthy Reno celebrity divorces. Early on it was a lot of actors from the Hollywood theatrical community, Nazi Goodwin and Virginia Harnet, the famous burlesque entertainer, Gypsy Rose Lee, divorced her third husband here. But then you can also think about socialites, you know, Vanderbilt's, Rockefellers, three of the children of Franklin and Eleanor Roosevelt got their divorces in Nevada.
劳拉·科里只是里诺一系列值得上头条的名人离婚案中的第一个。早期有很多来自好莱坞戏剧界的人，纳齐·古德温和弗吉尼亚·哈内特，著名的滑稽戏艺人吉普赛·罗斯·李，都在这里与她的第三任丈夫离婚。但你也可以想到名媛，你知道，范德比尔特家族、洛克菲勒家族，富兰克林和埃莉诺·罗斯福的三个孩子都在内华达州离了婚。
Soon enough, just a reference to Reno became shorthand for divorce. By 1910, the phrase, I'm on my way to Reno, or I'm going to Reno meant in people's minds I'm going to get a divorce. There was a popular song in 1910 called I'm on my way to Reno, and it was sung across the country. My wife and I don't get along with simply fighting fights.
很快，提到里诺就成了离婚的代名词。到1910年，“我在去里诺的路上”或“我要去里诺”这句话在人们心中意味着“我要去离婚”。1910年有一首流行的歌叫《我在去里诺的路上》，在全国各地传唱。“我和妻子相处得不好，总是吵架。我娶她是为了赢，这对我来说确实是对的。她曾经宣称对我的爱已经变成了恨。所以我决定去内华达州。我在去里诺的路上。我今天离开这个城镇，向百老汇所有的男孩女孩们致意。”随着内华达州金银矿的枯竭，里诺的政客和商人们正寻求利用围绕离婚旅游业兴起的新产业。内华达州并不是唯一注意到经济利益的西部州，
I married her to Winnerbett, it really does me right. The love she once declared was mine had simply turned to hate. So I made up my mind to visit all Nevada State. I'm on my way to Reno. I'm leaving town today in my regards to all the boys and girls along Broadway." With Nevada's gold and silver mining depleted, politicians and businessmen and Reno were looking to take advantage of this new industry cropping up around divorce tourism. Nevada wasn't the only Western state that noticed the economic benefit of
吸引离婚寻求者。阿肯色州、爱达荷州和怀俄明州也都降低了居住要求。南达科他州的苏福尔斯是第一批利用迁徙式离婚的城市之一，实际上被称为“离婚殖民地”。但当1929年股市崩盘时，有传言称爱达荷州和阿肯色州将效仿内华达州的居住要求，当时内华达州已经降至三个月。全国正进入大萧条，里诺的商业领袖们拼命想抓住唯一一个需求稳定的行业。于是，1931年，内华达州通过了立法，彻底巩固了里诺作为世界离婚之都的地位。
luring in divorce seekers. Arkansas, Idaho, and Wyoming had all lowered the residency requirements as well. Sioux Falls, South Dakota was one of the first cities to take advantage of migratory divorce and was actually known as a divorce colony. But when the stock market crashed in 1929, there were rumors that Idaho and Arkansas were going to match Nevada's residency requirement, which had actually been lowered to three months by then. The country was entering the depression and Reno business leaders were desperate to hold tight to the one industry that remained in steady demand. And so in 1931 Nevada passed legislation that solidified Reno once and for all as the divorce capital of the world.
州议会在1927年将居住期从六个月缩短到三个月，然后在1931年缩短到六周。只需六周即可建立居住权，内华达州里诺市提供了全国最快、最简单的离婚途径。这种快捷的途径不仅让富人和名人，也让那些没有奢侈时间从忙碌生活中抽出几个月的普通人获得了离婚的机会。在将里诺的居住期缩短到前所未有的六周的同一届立法会议上，内华达州还使公开赌博合法化。随着快捷离婚的提供，再加上纸牌、老虎机和骰子，里诺成为了离婚游客不可战胜的目的地。人们谈论说，你可以坐在里诺的主火车站，看着潮水涌入，看着“未婚者”离去。来里诺离婚的主要是女性，研究人员对此提供了一些解释。
The state legislature reduced that residency period from six months to three months in 1927 and then to six weeks in 1931. With just six weeks needed to establish residency, Reno, Nevada offered the quickest and easiest path to achieving a divorce in the country. This quick and easy pathway expanded access to divorce not just for the rich and famous, but every day people who didn't have the luxury to take months away from their busy lives. In the same legislative session that lowered Reno's residency to an unheard of six weeks, the state of Nevada also legalized wide open gambling. With the offer of a quickie divorce, along with a side of cards, slots, and dice, Reno became an unbeatable destination for divorce tourists. People talked about you could sit at the main train station in Reno and you could watch the tide come in and the untied go out. It was mostly women that came for the Reno divorce and researchers offer a few explanations
一个是当时中产阶级婚姻中，妻子不太可能在家庭外工作，因此有时间在州外逗留。离婚在技术上也属于一种诉讼，一方必须起诉另一方才能解除婚姻。因此，丈夫让妻子起诉自己离婚被视为一种绅士风度，因为这样他就不会玷污她的名声。这是一场诉讼。
for this. One is that in middle class marriages at the time, the wife would be less likely to work outside the home and therefore have the time to spend out of state. Divorce was also technically a type of lawsuit in which one partner had to sue the other to get out of the marriage. So it was seen as chivalrous for the husband to let his wife sue him for divorce because that way he wouldn't besmirch her reputation. It was a lawsuit.
你知道，一个人必须以某种理由起诉另一个人。你必须有起诉离婚的基础。与纽约州只有一个单一的法律离婚理由不同，内华达州有七个。范围从通奸到遗弃、监禁、后来的抛弃、无能，还有一个是极端残忍。残忍是里诺最常用的离婚理由，而且这是一个公开的秘密，它可以作为各种不满的“万能理由”。你不需要确凿的证据来证明精神残忍。
You know, one person had to sue the other on grounds. You had to have a basis for suing to divorce someone. Unlike New York, which just had one single legal ground for divorce, Nevada had seven. And they ranged from adultery to things like desertion, imprisonment, later abandonment, impudency, but also one was extreme cruelty. Brutti was by far the most used ground for divorce and reno, and it was an open secret that it could be used as a catch-all for all sorts of grievances. You didn't need corroborating evidence to prove mental cruelty.
一位丈夫声称妻子残忍，因为她批评他的驾驶技术。另一位说他的妻子指责他是德国间谍。还有人仅仅因为丈夫让她的生活变得枯燥而声称残忍。在我看来，这是离婚的正当理由。其中一个故事是，人们沿着特拉基河露营，因为是夏天，这样做很不错。他们只是在那里露营了六周。这是梅拉·罗斯韦尔-哈曼。梅拉写了关于大萧条时期里诺离婚贸易史的硕士论文。
One husband claimed cruelty by his wife because she criticized his driving. Another said his wife accused him of being a German spy. Another simply claimed cruelty because her husband made her life dull. Valid reason for a divorce in my opinion. One of the stories was that people were camping along the Trucky River, because it was summer, so it would be nice to do that. And they were just camping out for there six weeks. This is Mela Rothwell-Harmann. Mela wrote her master's thesis on the history of the divorce trade in Reno during the Great Depression.
她说，由于大多数离婚寻求者不想在户外艰苦地生活六周，当地人临时想办法来迎合这些临时居民的涌入。尽管处于大萧条时期，但建筑许可证却激增，因为人们争先恐后地建造公寓楼，扩建私人住宅将其变成寄宿公寓，并将车库改造成房产上的小木屋出租。你在里诺住在哪里，谁在那里见过你，是非常重要的信息，因为你需要在宣誓下提供这两者。你给出你的地址，然后在法庭上有一个人为你作证。
She says that since most divorce seekers didn't want to rough it outdoors for six weeks straight, locals improvised to cater to this influx of temporary residents. Even though it was a depression, that was a spike in building permits as people were rushing to build apartment houses and add on to their private homes to turn them into boarding houses and converting their garages to little cottages on their property to run it out. Were you stayed in Reno and who saw you there were very important pieces of information because you needed to provide both under oath. You give your address and then you have someone with you in court who would testify in your behalf.
他们称之为“居民证人”，他会证明你在六周内每天都被观察到在内华达州。许多招待所经理甚至主动提出担任所谓的“居民证人”，作为离婚套餐的一部分。有点像“来住我的旅馆，我就证明我六周里每天都见到你”。一位寻求离婚的女性最初在宣誓下撒谎，声称她在里诺待了要求的六周，而实际上只有四周。她因作伪证被送进监狱，但在刑期结束时，她有了无可辩驳的证据证明她在里诺待了整整六周。她的居民证人竟然就是县副警长。我同情这位寻求离婚的“监狱鸟”，
They call the resident witness who would testify that you had been observed in Nevada every day for the six weeks. Many guest house managers even offered to act as the so-called resident witness as part of a divorce seeking package deal. Kind of like come stay at my accommodations and I'll testify that I saw you every single day for six weeks. One divorce seeking woman initially lied under oath claiming that she had stayed in Reno for the required six weeks when in truth, it had only been four. She was sent to jail for committing perchray, but by the end of her sentence, she had incontrovertible proof that she was in Reno the whole six weeks. Her resident witness turned out to be none other than the county deputy. I feel for this divorce seeking jailbird
原因有很多，但其中之一是她被剥夺了情感支持，这种支持通常来自经营寄宿公寓的女性。她们被寄宿公寓经理收留，就像“房东妈妈”一样照顾她们，许多人写了一些非常可爱的评论，关于这些人有多重要。我读了一些20世纪30年代的留言簿评论，它们非常亲密。充满了内部笑话和强烈的感激之情，比如，引用：“你带走了我离婚的泪水。给了我一个理由去相信未来会幸福。”
for many reasons, but one is that she was denied the emotional support, which often came from the women who ran the boarding houses. They were taken in by the boarding house manager, oftentimes like a house mother, and cared for, and many people have written some really lovely comments about how important these people were. I read some of these guest book comments from the 1930s and they were so intimate. Full of inside jokes and intense gratitude, like, quote, you took my tears away over my divorce. Gave me a reason to think the future could be happy.
嗯，妈妈过去常试图安慰这些女士。这是乔莉·费波尼克。这是她家的留言簿。我读到她的祖母和母亲经营着一家俯瞰特拉基河的美丽离婚招待所。有时她们会和她们待到深夜，只是试图安慰她们。我想她们很感激，因为她性格开朗，非常外向幽默。有这样的陪伴真是一种乐趣，否则那可能是一个相当阴郁的家庭。当安·斯特姆的母亲来到里诺时，她不得不独自旅行，留下年幼的孩子六周。这一切都是为了一个她本来就不想要的离婚。当安·斯特姆的母亲来到里诺时，她不得不独自旅行，留下年幼的孩子
Well, mom used to try and console these ladies. This is joley fjjpehonic. It was her family's guest book. I read her grandmother and then mother ran a beautiful divorce guest house overlooking the trucky river. Sometimes they'd be up late at night with them just trying to console them. And I think they were grateful because she had this upbeat personality and was so outgoing and humorous. It was a delight to have that because otherwise it could be a pretty somber household. When Ann Sturm's mother came to Reno, she had to travel alone and leave her young children for six weeks. All for a divorce she didn't want in the first place. When Ann Sturms' mother came to Reno, she had to travel alone and leave her young children
六周，这一切都是为了一个她本来就不想要的离婚。我听过我父母吵架、争论，但我会和哥哥躺在床上哭。所以那是一个非常清晰的记忆。所以我知道她在睡觉，我知道她必须去里诺，她会离开六周。这对安的妈妈来说可能是一段令人沮丧和孤立的时光。但幸运的是，她有财力住在一个专门为离婚女性提供服务的豪华牛仔牧场。它甚至有供裸体日光浴的独立隔间。我母亲是个日光浴爱好者。
for six weeks, all for a divorce she didn't want in the first place. I had heard my father and mother fighting, arguing, but I'd get in bed with my brother and cry. So that was a very clear memory. So I knew she was sleeping and I knew that she had to go to Reno and that she would be gone six weeks. It could have been a depressing and isolating time for Anne's mom. But luckily she had the means to stay at a luxurious dude ranch catered specifically to divorce women. It even had individual stalls for nude sunbathing. My mother was a big sun lover.
裸体日光浴的隔间。我母亲是个日光浴爱好者。她带着一身没有痕迹的晒痕回家了。有一些非常有趣的老照片，展示了所有住在这些牛仔牧场的离婚女性，穿着牛仔装，
stalls for nude sunbathe thing. My mother was a big son lover. She came home with a no marks suntan. There are some really fun old photos of all the divorce seeking women that stayed at these dude ranches, wearing cowboy outfits,
一起吃晚餐，骑马。所以她去了那里，我想那里住满了许多其他女性。她们正在经历同样的事情。显然，她回家时比去的时候快乐多了，因为所有的那些治疗。你知道，那不是正式的治疗。那只是团体治疗，因为所有这些女性都在同一条船上。还有一点让里诺区别于其他离婚旅游目的地的是，
eating dinners together, and horseback riding. So she went there, and I guess it was full of lots of other women. They're going through the same thing. And obviously she came home much happier than when she went because of all that therapy. You know, it wasn't formal therapy. It was group therapy just because all of these women were in the same boat. Something else that set Reno apart from other divorce tourism destinations was that
它不仅对富有的白人女性开放。1950年《乌木》杂志的一篇专题文章报道说，每年约有500名黑人女性来到里诺离婚。这些女性需要依靠里诺当地的黑人社区来获得支持，当时这个社区非常小。我们也有一个非常强大的社区，因为它很小，而且她们在里诺不能做某些事情。这是谢恩·德尔·科恩。她是“我们的故事”公司的前董事会成员，这是一个致力于讲述内华达州北部历史上被低估的故事的非营利组织。
it wasn't only accessible to rich white women. One 1950 feature article in Ebony magazine reported that about 500 black women came to Reno to divorce each year. These women needed to rely on Reno's local black community for support, which at that time was very small. We also had a community that was very strong, as it was so small, and they couldn't do certain things in Reno. This is Shane Del Cohen. She's a former board member of our story, Inc., which is a non-profit devoted to stories that have been under
她说，来到城里离婚的黑人女性需要一个在白人主流之外运作的支持系统。尽管到20世纪中叶，该州的许多歧视性法律被推翻，但里诺仍然存在广泛的歧视。内华达州赢得了“西部密西西比”的绰号，因为其有公开的种族主义和排斥行为。所以如果你是一个黑人离婚寻求者，拥有当地的支持来帮助安全地在城市中穿行是至关重要的。
represented in northern Nevada history. She says black women coming into town for a divorce needed a support system that operated outside of the white mainstream. Although by the mid-1900s, many discriminatory laws were overturned in the state, there was still extensive discrimination in Reno. Nevada earned the nickname Mississippi of the West for having overtly racist and exclusionary practices. So if you were a black divorce seeker, it was essential to have local support to help navigate the city safely.
这种支持是由一个规模虽小但联系紧密的社区实现的，该社区由当地的非洲卫理公会圣公会教堂维系在一起。当时的社交生活围绕着贝尔街的AME教堂，它旁边有一家寄宿公寓，教堂以1.5美元的价格提供炸鸡晚餐。每个月，他们都有读书俱乐部，有一个小剧团，他们做各种各样的活动。那篇1950年的《乌木》杂志文章刊登了一张贝瑟尔教堂汤普森牧师的照片，
This support was made possible by a small, but tightly knit community held together by the local African Methodist Episcopal Church. The social life at that time was centered around the AME Church on Bell Street, which had a boarding house right next to it, and the church had chicken dinners for $1.50. Once a month, they had a book club, they had a little theatrical group, they did all sorts of things. That same 1950 article in Ebony Magazine features a photo of Reverend Thompson of the club, they had a little theatrical group. They did all sorts of things. That same 1950 article in Ebony magazine features a photo of Reverend Thompson of the Bethel
AME教堂欢迎陌生人时会问这个问题：“你是来寻求治愈的吗？”汤普森牧师所说的“治愈”是“六周治愈”。这个绰号指的是在里诺离婚所需的六周时间，从而从不幸的婚姻中得到治愈。我必须说，我最初对那个时代教会的欢迎程度感到困惑，因为当时离婚是非常禁忌的，所以我问了谢恩。是的，教会对婚姻和离婚的道德观相当保守。但他们的同情心并非如此。他们的同情心是包容一切的。但同情心再重要，也付不起账单。
AME who welcomed strangers with this question. Are you here for the cure? The cure Reverend Thompson was referring to is the six weeks cure. A nickname referring to the six weeks it took to get a divorce in Reno and therefore be cured from your miserable marriage. I have to say I was initially confused by how welcoming the church was in an era when divorce was super taboo and so I asked Shane about that. Yes, the church ethic towards marriage and divorce was pretty conservative. But their compassion wasn't. Their compassion was all encompassing. But as important as the compassion was, it couldn't pay the bills.
许多来到里诺的人在六周的逗留期间也需要钱。他们需要一份工作。许多离婚寻求者在里诺期间需要找到工作，以支付离婚费用和居住费用。男性和女性都有工作机会。在里诺寻求离婚的男性可以找到机械师或牧场工人的工作。甚至著名的黑人马克思主义作家C.L.R.詹姆斯在1948年因离婚在城里时，也曾做过牧场工人。如果你是女性，你可以去基督教女青年会（YWCA），它会帮你安排一份
Many of the people who came to Reno also needed money during their six weeks day. They needed a job. A number of the divorce seekers needed to find a job while they were in Reno in order to pay for their divorce and their residency here. And there were jobs available for both men and women. Men seeking divorces in Reno could find work as a mechanic or a ranch aunt. Even famous black marxist writer CLR James got work as a ranch aunt while he was in town for a divorce in 1948. If you were a woman, you could head over to the YWCA, which would help set you up with
短期工作，比如店员、女服务员、管家或速记员，或者你可以在里诺著名的众多机构中找到工作。里诺的赌场业既是离婚寻求者的娱乐场所，也是就业场所。在旅游业之前，赌博大多发生在后室，针对的是更粗犷的当地人群。但随着城里离婚游客的涌入，赌场老板们正在寻找新的方式来吸引这些中产阶级游客。有一家非常著名的俱乐部叫哈罗德俱乐部，开业于20世纪30年代，它开始通过一种真正的卡通式、西部风格的主题来宣传自己，这让它看起来更像是体面的娱乐，而不仅仅是
a short-term gig like shop clerk, waitress, housekeeper, or stenographer, or you could find work in one of the many institutions Reno was famous for. Reno's casino industry was both entertainment for the divorce seekers, as well as a place for employment. Before the tourism industry, gambling mostly took place in back rooms and was geared towards a rougher local crowd. But with the flood of divorce tourists in town, casino owners were looking for new ways to appeal to these middle-class visitors. There was a very famous club called Haralds Club, that opened to the 1930s, that started to promote itself through a real kind of cartoony, western kind of theming that made it seem more like respectable fun and not just
某种某种活动。艾丽西亚·巴伯再次表示，提高体面度的一个策略是雇佣女性，有一个工作完全适合里诺赌博和离婚的交汇点。那就是“托儿”（shill）。有一种工作叫“托儿”，吸引人的女性会被雇佣坐在桌游旁，玩游戏并表现出很高兴的样子，试图吸引其他人过来。
some kind of sort of activity. Alicia Barber, again, she says one tactic of increasing respectability was hiring women, and there was one job completely perfect for the Reno intersection of gambling and divorce. The shill. There was a job known as a shill, where attractive women would be hired to just sit at one of the table games and play the game and look delighted, and try to attract other people to come.
2014年，梅拉·哈蒙采访了一位名叫珍妮丝的女士，她的母亲在1944年去里诺寻求离婚时被雇为“托儿”。当她去离婚时，她必须想办法谋生，因为她要在那里待六周，而且我也认为她在那里待六周试图找点事做时已经无聊透顶了。所以，但她是个非常好的牌手。她告诉我：“我不知道他们雇佣托儿。”你知道吗？但她说她会坐在二十一点桌旁。甚至有一个当地女性的故事，
In 2014, Mela Harmon spoke with a woman named Janice, whose mother was hired as a shill when she was out in Reno seeking a divorce in 1944. When she went up to get her divorce, she had to figure out a way to earn a living because she was going to be there for six weeks and I also think she'd been bored to tears sitting up there for six weeks trying to find something to do. So, but she was a very good card player. And she told me I didn't know they hired shields. You know what? But she said she'd sit at the black check table. There's even a story of a local woman
在同一家赌场申请工作时，她回忆说每个人都在问她：“你确定你不是来离婚的吗？”普遍的印象是，你知道，里诺人对此感到相当有趣，并认为：“哇，这太棒了。”所以有很多流行文化。然后这种宣传确实是自我强化的。所以里诺的推动者不需要做任何事情就能获得这种宣传，因为
applying for a job at the same casino who recalled that everyone kept asking her, are you sure you're not here for a divorce? The general impression was that, you know, Renoites were pretty amused by it and thought, wow, this is just great, you know. So there was a lot of popular culture. And then this was the kind of publicity that really fed upon itself. So Reno's promoters didn't have to do anything to get this kind of publicity because the
媒体对此非常着迷。在引人入胜的报纸头条之间，美国公众从好莱坞电影中获得了源源不断的里诺离婚剧。真正从20世纪30年代开始，有很多。1931年就有三部在制作中。这简直是戏剧的沃土。甚至玛丽莲·梦露的最后一部电影《乱点鸳鸯谱》（The Misfits）也是关于里诺离婚的。
media was just fascinated by it. In between juicy newspaper headlines, the American public was fed a steady stream of Reno divorce drama from Hollywood films. Really starting in the 1930s, there were a lot. There were three in production in 1931. It was just fertile ground for drama. Even Marilyn Monroe's last film, The Miss Fits, was about a Reno divorce.
在这一幕中，她站在著名的弗吉尼亚街大桥上，考虑扔掉自己的戒指。“继续吧，我知道每个人都这么做。那条河里的金子比桂河里的还要多。”对所有这些女性来说，个人利害关系很高，而里诺实现了这一点。它是逃避社会禁忌的避难所，是获得工作经验的机会，也是通往更充实的婚姻和财务保障的潜在途径。如果你设法戴上牛仔帽，玩老虎机并在此过程中玩得开心，那只是额外收获。里诺的离婚时代在20世纪60年代末开始逐渐消失，因为离婚法变得更加自由化，
In the scene, she stands on the famous Virginia Street Bridge and contemplates throwing her own ring in. Go ahead and I know everybody does this. More gold and that river than the river than the river in the Kwanai. The personal stakes were high for all of these women and Reno delivered. It was a refuge from social taboos, an opportunity for job experience, and a potential pathway to a more fulfilling marriage with financial security. If you manage to wear a cowboy hat, play the slots and have fun while at it, that was just a bonus. Reno's divorce era began petering out in the late 1960s, as divorce law became more liberalized
在整个西方世界。内华达州的迁徙式离婚产业在20世纪60年代随着全国范围内“不可调和的分歧”和“无过错离婚”的引入而真正结束。1969年，加利福尼亚州成为第一个引入“不可调和的分歧”和“无过错离婚”的州。此前，一方必须以特定理由起诉另一方才能解除婚姻。比如通奸，或者成为德国间谍。但“无过错离婚”意味着你不再需要证明不当行为。
throughout the Western world. The migratory divorce industry in Nevada really ended in the 1960s with the introduction of irreconcilable differences and no fault divorce throughout the country. In 1969, California became the first state to introduce irreconcilable differences and no fault divorce. Previously, one spouse had to sue the other in order to get out of a marriage on specific grounds. Like adultery, we're being a germist by. But no fault divorce meant you didn't need to prove wrongdoing anymore.
其他州很快效仿加利福尼亚州，通过了类似的离婚法。这基本上就结束了它，因为那时在其他地方离婚并不比在内华达州更难。在内华达州可能更快，但你不再需要起诉这一事实，使得它在全国范围内更广泛地可用和高效。里诺保持了六十多年的“世界离婚之都”称号，并帮助结束了数以万计的婚姻。尽管今天的游客可能不知道里诺的离婚历史，但它永远改变了这座城市的身份。正是离婚在很大程度上激发了我们拥有的这个口号，
Other states quickly followed California's lead and adopted similar divorce laws. And that really pretty much put an end to it, because then it wouldn't be any harder to really get a divorce in other places than it was in Nevada. It might be faster in Nevada, but the fact that you didn't have to sue anymore just made it more widely available and efficient throughout the country. Reno held the title of Divorce Capital the World for a little over six decades and helped to bring an end to tens of thousands of marriages. Even though today visitors may not be aware of Reno's divorce history, it altered the identity of the city forever. It was divorced that really was largely the inspiration for this slogan that we have
你知道，也就是“世界上最大的小城市”。这是关于这样一个事实：就其规模而言，这是一个小巧、谦逊的西部小镇，里诺比你预期的要国际化得多。在许多方面，这是因为你有所有这些从外面来离婚的人，他们来自更国际化的城市中心。他们带来了一些东西。这确实留在了里诺，这确实在结合了
for, you know, which is the biggest little city in the world. That was about the fact that for its size, which was small, modest, little western town, Reno was so much more cosmopolitan than you would expect. And that, in many ways, was due to the fact that you had all of these people coming from outside to get divorces from much more cosmopolitan urban centers. And they brought something with them. And that did stay with Reno, and that really, in combination then
赌博合法化之后，创造了内华达州至今仍在持续的旅游业。现在，在里诺作为世界离婚之都的统治结束50年后，我走近弗吉尼亚街大桥，这座女性几十年来抛弃结婚戒指的桥，被眼前的景象震惊了。天哪，这里现在有爱情锁了。讽刺！
with the legalization of gambling, created the tourism industry that has continued to this day in the state of Nevada. And now, a good 50 years after the end of Reno's reign as the divorce capital of the world, I approached the Virginia Street Bridge, the bridge where women cast off their wedding rings for decades and was shocked by a sight. Oh my god, there's love locks here now. Ironic!
爱情锁。就像你在著名桥梁上偶尔看到的那些挂锁。情侣们刻上名字缩写，把锁锁在桥上，然后扔掉钥匙，这一切都象征着牢不可破的爱情之类的东西。不用说，我被这个发现吓了一跳，然后感到恼火。这是一座解放之桥，怎么敢被字面上代表枷锁的关系所破坏？但后来，直到最近，我才知道里诺著名的赌场是那些婚姻不幸女性的雇主。所以也许我也错过了这些锁背后的故事。
Love locks. Like those padlocks, you sometimes see on famous bridges. That thing where a couple inscribes their initials attaches the lock the bridge, and then throws away the key, all to symbolize unbreakable love or whatever. Needless to say, I was startled, then annoyed by this discovery. This was a bridge of liberation, how dare it be vandalized by relationships literally represented by shackles. But then, up until recently, I had no idea Reno's famous casinos were employers of unhappily married women. So maybe I was missing the story behind these locks, too.
这是关于爱你自己。也许这些锁是献给自爱的。我在开什么玩笑？但至少，这些情侣已经知道了一个离婚的好地方。休息之后，艾莉回来告诉我另一个访问里诺并写了一本非常有影响力的书的加拿大人。所以我们回到了制片人艾莉·戈登-莫沙尔身边。非常感谢你的故事，艾莉。这是一个有趣的离婚故事。我告诉过你会的。我知道，你做到了。但我故事中没有提到的一件事是，我实际上带了我的女朋友去我的里诺离婚之旅。带着伴侣去执行你的离婚故事，这是一种奇怪的情侣度假。
It's about love of yourself. Maybe these are locks dedicated to self-love. Who am I kidding? But at the very least, these couples already know of a fun place to get divorced. After the break, Ellie comes back to tell me about a different Canadian who visited Reno and wrote a very influential book about it. So we're back with producer Ellie Gordon-Morshal. Thank you so much for that story, Ellie. It was a fun divorce story. I told you it would be. I know and you delivered. But one thing I did not mention in the story is that I actually brought my girlfriend on my Reno divorce trip. That's kind of a strange couple's getaway to do your divorce story with your partner.
好吧，我觉得这很浪漫。但在那里的一个下午，我们试图找一些明信片。首先，在一家真正的女权主义书店兼猫咪领养中心，但遗憾的是它关门了。然而，隔壁有人发现了我们，有点像：“哦，你们为什么不进来看看呢？”结果那个地方是北内华达LGBTQ中心。不错。所以当我告诉执行董事我们为什么在城里时，她说：“哦，过来看看这个。”她展开了一张巨大的电影海报。上面是一辆1950年代的敞篷车。
Okay, I think it's romantic. But one of the afternoons who are there, we were trying to find some postcards. First, at an actual feminist bookstore slash cat adoption center, but it was closed, sadly. However, next door, someone had spotted us and kind of was like, oh, why don't you come in here and check things out? And it turned out that place was the Northern Nevada LGBTQ center. Nice. And so when I told the executive director why we were in town, she was like, oh, come here and take a look at this. And she rolled out a big movie poster. And on it was a 1950s convertible.
有两个女人站在前面，一个穿着朴素的白色高跟鞋，另一个穿着酷酷的牛仔靴。顶部的口号写着：1959年，薇薇安·贝尔来到里诺寻求快捷离婚。在她遇到的所有人中，最让她惊讶的是她自己。所以我立刻认出了它，
There's two women standing in front, one in modest white heels, and the other in like cool cowboy boots. And the slogan across the top red, in 1959 Vivian Bell came to Reno for a quicky divorce. Of all the people she met there, the one that most surprised her was herself. So I recognized it immediately,
因为它是一部叫《沙漠之心》（Desert Hearts）的电影，在酷儿社区很受欢迎，因为它是第一部有圆满结局的主流女同性恋电影。哇，好的，那这部电影是哪一年出的？它是在1985年出的，实际上是我出生的那一年，但这只是我所知道的那些事情和电影之一，你知道，
because it's for this film called Desert Hearts, which is beloved in the queer community because it was the first mainstream lesbian film to have a happy ending. Wow, okay, so what year did this come out? It came out in 1985, which is actually the year I was born, but it was just one of those things and films I just knew about, you know,
就像女同性恋电影宇宙里的东西，但这部电影实际上是基于1964年出版的一本小说，叫《沙漠之心》（Desert of the Heart），作者叫简·鲁尔。多告诉我一些关于简·鲁尔的事。她也是加拿大人，于2007年去世。尽管我没听说过她，但她在某些圈子里是一位著名的文学人物。我想说她是玛格丽特·阿特伍德的闺蜜。事实证明，简·鲁尔的档案在
like out of the lesbian cinematic universe, but the film was actually based on a novel that came out in 1964 called Desert of the Heart by an author named Jane Rool. Tell me more about Jane Rool. She was a fellow Canadian, and she did pass away in 2007. And even though I hadn't heard of her, she was a well-known literary figure in some circles. I would say she was besties with Margaret Atwood. It turns out Jane rules archives are at
不列颠哥伦比亚大学。当我翻阅它们时，我觉得好像有几百封阿特伍德的信。而且肤浅地说，我必须……当我翻阅它们时，我觉得好像有几百封阿特伍德的信。而且肤浅地说，我必须说，看到玛格丽特·阿特伍德的笔迹和我的一样糟糕，我感到很高兴。她们就像我们一样。那么告诉我简与里诺的联系，是什么促使她写这本书的？是的，我大约一年前读了《沙漠之心》。这就是我发现里诺离婚历史的方式。这就是为什么会有这一集。而且与电影版不同，书中有太多关于那个年长的角色来到城里进行里诺离婚的细节。其中的细节让我觉得简一定去过里诺，但我只是在网上研究中找不到这一点。
the University of British Columbia. And when I was looking through them, I felt like there was like hundreds of letters from Atwood. And on a shallow note, I have to when I was looking through them, I felt like there was like hundreds of letters from Atwood and on a shallow note, I have to say I was pleased to see that Margaret Atwood's handwriting is just as bad as mine. They're just like us. So tell me about Jane's connection to Reno, like what prompted her to write this book? Yeah, so I've read Desert of the Heart about a year ago. That is how I found out about the Reno divorce history. That's why this episode exists. And unlike the movie version, there's just so much detail about the older character coming into town for a Reno divorce. And the detail of it made me think like Jane must have gone to Reno, but I just I just could not find that out in the research online.
去过里诺，但我只是在网上研究中找不到这一点。但后来一个朋友的朋友发邮件说：“我很确定简的长期伴侣海伦去里诺离过婚。”我当时就想：“天哪！”我太兴奋了。这就是我最初去档案馆的原因。是的，果然，海伦确实去里诺离过婚，简也陪着她。所以这本书是64年出的。那么她是什么时候经历里诺的？她在1958年就在那里了，那接近里诺作为离婚之都的尾声，但我会说它可能仍然非常处于那个鼎盛时期。简曾写信给她的父母说，海伦在她的家乡州无法离婚，
gone to Reno, but I just could not find that out in the research online. But then an acquaintance of a friend emailed and was like, I'm pretty sure James Long-term partner Helen went to Reno for a divorce. And I was like, oh my god, and I was so excited. And that's why I went to the archives in the first place. And yeah, sure enough, Helen did travel to Reno for a divorce and Jane went with her. So the book came out in 64. So when did she experience Reno? She was there in 1958, which was nearing the end of sort of Reno being the divorce capital, but I would say it probably still was very much experiencing the heyday of that. And Jane had written to her parents that Helen couldn't get a divorce in her home state,
去了里诺，但我无法在网上的研究中查到这一点。但后来一位朋友的熟人发邮件说，我很确定詹姆斯的长期伴侣海伦去里诺离了婚。我当时简直惊呆了，非常兴奋。这就是我最初去档案馆的原因。没错，海伦确实去了里诺离婚，简也陪她一起去了。这本书出版于64年，那么她是什么时候经历里诺的呢？她在1958年去了那里，当时里诺作为离婚之都的地位已接近尾声，但我认为它当时可能仍处于鼎盛时期。简曾写信告诉父母，海伦无法在她所在的州离婚，
Massachusetts, because most of the judges were Catholic. And while they were both in Reno, Jane actually got a job at a casino. Oh, we see one of the chills you were talking about. She did learn about chills from an employment agency, and she did try and get a job as one at the MAPES casino, which is actually where Desert Hearts was filmed decades later. But the manager took one look at her and said, sorry, lady.
马萨诸塞州，因为大多数法官都是天主教徒。当她们俩都在里诺时，简确实在一家赌场找到了一份工作。哦，我们看到了你提到的其中一个“托儿”。她确实从一家职业介绍所了解到了“托儿”的工作，并且确实尝试在MAPES赌场应聘，而几十年后《沙漠之心》正是在那里拍摄的。但经理看了她一眼就说，抱歉，女士。
And this is just me guessing, but I think it's because Jane Ruel was a six foot tall lesbian. I see. So she wasn't like the typical shill material. No, she was not. But she did end up getting a job at Harold's Club. And so what did she do for Harold? She had this job called Change Girl, which involved lugging around 40 pounds of coins for customers that needed to break their bills for the slots. And she wrote an excited letter to her parents about the job, and that the experience was probably
这只是我的猜测，但我认为是因为简·鲁尔是一位六英尺高的女同性恋者。我明白了。所以她不像典型的“托儿”人选。不，她不是。但她最终在哈罗德俱乐部找到了一份工作。那么她为哈罗德做了什么呢？她有一份叫做“换币女孩”的工作，这涉及到为需要将钞票换成老虎机硬币的顾客搬运40磅重的硬币。她给父母写了一封兴奋的信，讲述了这份工作，并说这段经历可能
destined to give her writing material, which of course it was. And then the bonus of a frontier outfit that she could bring back to Vancouver. Okay, so she's down there with Helen. I assume Helen got her divorce. So what happens then? Yeah, she got her divorce. Her and Jane went back up to BC. And in one of the letters I saw written, you know, during this time, Jane got her divorce. Her and Jane went back up to BC. And in one of the letters I saw written during this time, Jane mentioned her own marital status.
注定会给她提供写作素材，当然确实如此。还有一个额外的好处，就是她可以带回温哥华的一套边境风格服装。好吧，所以她和海伦在那里。我假设海伦离婚了。那后来发生了什么？是的，她离婚了。她和简回到了不列颠哥伦比亚省。在我看到的一封信中，你知道，在那段时间里，简提到了她自己的婚姻状况。
She was writing to her parents. She was responding to what must have been a letter about them being worried that Jane herself would never get married. And so Jane was writing them back and said, I haven't the biggest desire to get married. And then she goes on to say that she doesn't feel too guilty about it because I'm fairly sure that you're rather fond of who I am, which is very sweet. She wrote them a lot.
她当时正在给父母写信。她是在回应一封信，信中他们一定很担心简本人永远不会结婚。于是简回信说，我一点也不想结婚。然后她继续说，她对此并不感到太内疚，因为“我很确定你们相当喜欢现在的我”，这非常贴心。她给他们写了很多信。
Yeah, that's very sweet. So Helen passes away in 2000, which is before gay marriage is legalized in Canada. But I have to say like knowing what I know about Jane rule, I really don't think they would have ever married anyway, but they stayed together for the rest of their lives, and their ashes are at the Galliano Island cemetery. And so where is Galliano Island?
是的，那非常贴心。海伦于2000年去世，那是在加拿大同性婚姻合法化之前。但我不得不说，根据我对简·鲁尔的了解，我真的认为她们无论如何都不会结婚，但她们余生一直在一起，她们的骨灰安葬在加利亚诺岛公墓。那么加利亚诺岛在哪里？
It's actually pretty close to Vancouver. It's part of the Gulf Islands that are just a fairy ride away. And Roman, I didn't plan this, but my girlfriend, and I actually booked a cabin for the weekend right before this episode drops on Galliano Island. And a couple days ago, I looked up the cemetery and our cabin is literally steps away. Wow. Wow. That's so cool. So you're going to go and pay your respects. I definitely will. I want to thank Jane for introducing me to Reno. Well, I'm glad she introduced you to Reno. And then I'm glad that you introduced us to Reno.
它离温哥华其实很近。它是海湾群岛的一部分，坐渡轮就能到。罗曼，我不是有意安排的，但我女朋友和我确实预订了这集节目发布前周末在加利亚诺岛的小木屋。几天前，我查了那个公墓，我们的小木屋离那里简直只有几步之遥。哇。哇。太酷了。所以你要去表达敬意。我一定会去的。我想感谢简带我认识了里诺。好吧，我很高兴她带你认识了里诺。我也很高兴你带我们认识了里诺。
So thanks so much. Thank you. Thank you. 99% of us vote with Brutes this week by Ellie Gordon-Morshal, edited by Vivian Leigh. Sound mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Rihall, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Special thanks this week to Marie and Laura Joe.
非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由艾莉·戈登-莫沙尔报道，薇薇安·李编辑。声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯负责，音乐由斯旺·里霍尔创作，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙负责。本周特别感谢玛丽和劳拉·乔。
Our executive producer is Kathy too. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Kohlstedt is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Sarah Baker, Chris Barouba, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Jason Dalyone, Lashemadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below goatgo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
我们的执行制片人是凯西·图。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特是我们的数字总监。团队其他成员包括莎拉·贝克、克里斯·巴鲁巴、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、杰森·戴利昂、拉舍马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作。
We are a part of the Stitcher and Series XM podcast family, now a headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on most social media platforms, but those feel pretty bad these days, but I can't recommend one place that does feel good. Our website, 99pi.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是Stitcher和Series XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。非常漂亮。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在大多数社交媒体平台上找到我们，但这些平台现在感觉不太好，但我可以推荐一个感觉不错的地方。我们的网站，99pi.org。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。